we start with the reunion this morning a
new local family thought they lost
everything after their U-Haul was stolen
certainly not the best way to be
introduced to our city here in Las Vegas
but as Madison Kimbrough learned there
was a holiday miracle
all of our belongings
from the move from the move everything
our whole life yeah just left in there
and someone took it not an ideal way
someone wants to start out a
cross-country move let alone the holiday
season Melissa Bayer her husband Adam
and their six children moved from Maine
to Las Vegas just last week for a fresh
start but then woke up on November 21st
to their U-Haul truck and suv gone from
where they parked it alongside Rochelle
Avenue all the sentimental things that
were in there our kids were just they
were devastated we found the lock on the
grounds from the Su from the U-Haul door
someone just popped it out and just
drove off with everything after filing a
police report and posting to social
media Melissa received a tip on
Thanksgiving night that their U-Haul and
SUV was parked just a couple blocks away
and miraculously most of the family's
belongings were still inside a lot of
the stuff that was in the front of the
U-Haul is missing
um I'm just thankful that what was in
the back it was my kids belongings most
of them in the back and the sentimental
things were in the back and they weren't
they weren't touched as for insurance
the bear family had what was offered to
them through U-Haul but that only covers
the U-Haul itself and none of their
personal belongings and overall while
they are Beyond grateful they got most
of their personal items back this whole
ordeal has them rethinking how they
would handle a move like this in the
future I wish we would have done more I
wish we would have had our own GPS our
own alarm maybe put a boot on the the
wheel I wish we would have done more to
prevent this from happening because the
U-Haul was way too easy to break into
and Steel Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now
and this morning police are still
searching for the people who stole the
family's U-Haul and SUV